في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي اعلنت اوكرانيا
انها تمكنت للمره الاولى من اسقاط طائره
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراز الشاهد 136
في منطقه خاركيز وتستخدمها القوه الروسيه
اعتذارك بضعه اسابيع بعد ان كشف مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سوليفان عازم
روسيا شراء مئات من الطائره القتاليه
الايرانيه بدون طيار لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا نفذ طهران رسميا ان يكون لديها
نيه لبيع طائره مسيره لروسيا وانما سلمته
منها كان قبل حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
اللافته هو ان الاهتمام بهذه المسيرات
ياتي لتميزها بقدرات تحليق طويله وتنوع
اغراضها بين المراقبه والاستطلاع العسكري
ولهجوم بالذخائر الناريه او بالاصطدام
بالهدف والانفجار من ابرازها المسيرته
الصغيره تشاهد 100 و 36 او طائره
الكاميكازي تزيين نحو 200 كيلو غرام
وتعتبر رخيصه لتطلب حقيمتها بين 520000
دولار مقارنه كمثال بكلفه الصواريخ كاليبر
او توماهوك
تطلقوه على شكل اسراب ولانها بطيئه ولا
تستطيع التحليق على ارتفاعات عاليه يتم
اعتراض عدد كبير منها لكن نفذها مسيره او
اثنتين بنحو 40 كلغراما كافر لاحداث ذمار
كبيره المسيره الاخرى التي اعتقد ان ايران
بعتها لروسيا هي مهاجر سته التي تستخدم في
مهام المراقبه والاستطلاع والتصوير
والهجوم وبدات ايران انتاجها عام 2018
ساعه ويبلغ مداها اكثر من 2000 كلم وهذه
المسيره مجاهزه بكاميرا حراريه وبصريه
وتحمل اربعه قنابل ذكيه دقيقه وتشبه من
حيث الوظيفه والحجم مسيره باقدار اثنين
تركيا وما قد يعكس اهتمامه طهران بهذه
الصناعه افتتاح رئيس كان الجيش الايراني
محمد باقر مصنعا لانتاج طائره استطلاع
مسيره من طراز ابابيل 2 في العاصمه
التاجيكيه ديشامبا فيما يويار الماضي